you getting cool points for being
britney spears as mom
i guess sometimes a source tells e.t
brittany has been much happier lately
and well it shows
the 39 year old looked upbeat during a
starbucks run with her boyfriend sam and
her 14 year old son jaden it's the first
time spears has been spotted out since
the release of the documentary
framing britney spears
our source says the docs inspired an
outpouring of support for brit
and she's feeling the love and brittany
was all smiles in a new video posted
this morning
where she took fans inside her closet
and modeled eight different outfits
so what's next a tell-all interview a
source tells e.t
britney has considered speaking out
about her past and quote
she's always hated doing interviews but
if she ever takes that step
oprah would most likely be her first
choice what
we're told however there are currently
no plans in the works for a britney sit
down and a move like that would require
a number of complicated steps
due to her conservatorship and there's
news on that front
a crowd of free britney protesters
showed up outside yesterday's hearing
to support the star brit's attorney
wants to make jodie montgomery a
permanent conservator
in charge of her personal day-to-day
life will you be taking over now
for jamie her dad jamie however would
still be in the picture
overseeing his daughter's finances
you